bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les grandes
lignes de cette émission Jean-Marc ho
était aujourd'hui en visite à Gif
surivette le chantier d'un centre de
recherche EDF débute le projet Paris
saclé semble enfin
lcé SEP syndicalistes sud de PSA poissis
sont en grève de la fin depuis le 18
septembre cela fait maintenant 22 jours
qu'il proteste contre une discrimination
syndicale et de mauvaises conditions de
travail les jeunes sont une des
populations les plus touchées par le
chômage 24,6 % dans les quartiers
populaires les données peuvent doubler
nous ferons le point dans le département
dans d'autres dossiers de la semaine et
puis nous parlerons de la plateforme
bouger vers l'emploi inaugurée ce lundi
à trappe ce service permet à des
personnes de retrouver un emploi en leur
proposant des solutions de déplacement
adapté max décormier directeur de la
plateforme nous expliquera son action il
n'a pas pu être en plateau avec nous
mais nous l'aurons par téléphone on
passe à l'actualité économique de la
semaine ce matin comme je vous le disais
Jean-Marc HRO était à Gif sur Ivette il
inaugurait un centre de recherche EDF
dans le cadre du projet scientifique
Paris sa clé véritable silicone valallé
à la française le chantier initié par
Nicolas Sarkozi en 2007 semble enfin
lancer reportage d'Olivier Maniscalco et
Patrick Jacques de
Dixmude mesdames messieurs il est
toujours un moment dans l'élaboration
d'un grand projet où tout
bascule tout bascule du rêve à la
réalité et je crois qu'avec Paris saclé
nous sommes à ce moment-là vous devons
en vous devez nous devons en être
parfaitement conscient le chantier de de
la silicone vallée à la française c'est
parti initié dès 2007 le projet Paris sa
clé a enfin bouclé son financement et
peut donc démarrer le Premier ministre
jean-marquud était ce matin sur le
campus à Gif sur iivette pour inaugurer
le centre de recherche et développement
deedf il en a profité pour annoncer que
85 millions d'euros seraient débloqués
pour la création d'un centre de
recherche sur les énergies décarboné
projet scientifique unique en France
Paris sa clé va proposer une idée simple
faire se croiser sur un même étudiants
chercheurs enseignants et le monde de
l'entreprise le but être à la pointe de
l'innovation et faciliter la création de
startup axé sur les technologies de
demain en fait en France on a pas mal de
PME on a pas mal de start-up le problème
c'est qu' une espèce de plateforme verre
et nous ce qu'on pense c'est que par la
proximité du centre de de recherche de
de Paris de Paris saclcly et bien on va
être un vecteur qui va aider ces PME à
croître c'est quand même la recette qui
a fait que B la Cicon valallleé et la
Cicon valallley nous avec notre génie
français ben on veut faire la même chose
mais avec nos moyens et avec notre
inventivité selon les prévisions d'ici à
2030 600000 m² de locaux d'enseignement
de bureau et de logement verront le jour
côté transport une liaison directe est
prévue entre l'aéroport dorli et
versaill 1/5e de la recherche française
devrait se regrouper à terme sur 7700
hactares de terrain le coût total du
projet est estimé à près de 2,5
milliards
d'euros devant le PO è de PSA Peugeot à
poissi 7p syndicalistes sont en grèff de
la fin ils ne comptent s'arrêter
qu'après obtention de leur revendication
de meilleures conditions de travail
notamment nous sommes allés à la
rencontre ce mardi un reportage réalisé
avec Eléodie moine 20 jours de grève de
la fin 20 jours que ces SEP ouvriers
syndicalistes sud de PSA poissi campent
devant les bureaux de leur direction
leur combat dénoncé leurs conditions de
travail et le harcèlement moral qu'ils
subissent mais pour le moment leurs
revendications sont restées être morte
alors leur lutte continue malgré les
alertes des médecins j'ai un problème
cardiaque et je refuse
d'arrêter je préfère crever ici et ne
pas lâcher on a un colollé qui dort dans
l'attente il a perdu 21 kg et quand il
marche il fait comme ça PSA c'estd
l'indifférence totale la direction
jointe par téléphone n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer un comité de soutien
solidaire rassemblant association parti
syndicat a été créé le 3 octobre les
membres se reléent pour soutenir les
grévistes aujourd'hui c'était a tour
d'Olivier besancen l'espoir qu'on a on
verra ce qui se passe donc le 10
aprèsdemain aussi autour de l'accord
compétitivité si si ça peut être aussi
un moyen de tout faire ressurgir à la
surface quoi voilà pas simplement les
accords de compétitivité mais aussi ce
qu'il y a derrière est ce qui vous
arrive aussi les autres syndicats ne
soutiennent pas leur mouvement mais ét
Unis le 3 octobre lors d'une
mobilisation nationale contre l'accord
compétitivité samedi les gréistes
invitent leur soutien à une marche vers
la mairie à 14h
suite à ce reportage réalisé mardi nous
avons reconacté les gréistes aujourd'hui
ils ont rencontré la direction ils
attendent maintenant une réponse à leur
revendication et le médiateur régional
du travail manquait cependant lui à
l'appel les clients des banques ne sont
pas tous logés à la même enseigne c'est
le constat d'une étude du comparateur
panoraban.com les coûts varient selon
l'âge le sexe et le revenu mais
également selon le lieu de résidence
l'île-de-fance est une des régions les
moins chères des frais de moins de 185 €
par
an mercredi la Chambre des Métiers et de
l'Artisanat et Pôle emploi ont signé une
convention de partenariat le but mettre
en commun leur expertise et leur offre
de service on écoute les directeurs de
ces deux
entités lorsqu'on travaille auprès des
entreprises on on va informer l'ensemble
des entreprises et avec la chambre de
métier on regarde l'information des
entreprises artisanales par contre sur
la partie formation là on on s'adresse à
tous les demandeurs d'emploi et
l'appareil de formation vise à à aider
les demand emplois à créer leur
entreprise on a commencé à œuvrer fin de
l'année dernière et au jour
d'aujourd'hui on a déjà formé accueilli
on a déjà accueilli 155 personnes
intéressées par notre dispositif donc la
réussite totale de ce rapprochement la
Fashion Week se tenait la semaine
dernière à Paris mais à Saint-Quentin en
Eveline aussi on parle mode nous avons
rencontré la gérante d'un magasin de
prête à porter pour petite taille colili
un magasin en ligne des images de
Jonathan villman derrière ce site
internet de prête à porortter se cache
une nimontaine après 25 ans passés dans
la documentation Corine a tout
simplement changé de vie et a créé sa
propre entreprise il y a un an et demi
j'étais déjà depuis quelques années en
je dirais en en mode réflexion
j'hésitais je savais pas j'avais fait
des formations j'avais fait un bilan de
compétences je refaisais de l'intérim je
je recherchais quelque chose je ne
savais pas quoi et puis d'un seul coup
il y a eu
l'idée l'idée est enfin arrivée l'idée
proposer des vêtements pour des femmes
de petite taille 1,60 ou moins fini les
vêtements trop longs trop larg mal
taillé ou encore la collection enfant du
haut de son M50 Corine a créé elle-même
son magasin idéal dans un premier temps
sur le net pour toucher un public plus
large mais en plus de cette boutique
virtuelle Corine transforme son
appartement en showroom quand les
clientes veulent venir essayer la
collection ici vous ne trouverez que des
collections de styliste français je
m'attache à faire du MadeIn France pour
faire travailler des entreprises
françaises pour avoir des des vêtements
de qualité avec des tissus de qualité je
je je recherche également des tissus bio
ces pièces elle les déniche sur les
salons ou en furtant sur des blocs de
mode compter environ 100 € pour un
article bijoux et accessoires lui
permettent de diversifier son offre pour
le moment Cory ne peut pas vivre de son
activité mais elle garde bon espoir sa
clientèle a déjà dépassé les frontières
de
l'Hexagone et à noter selon la
Fédération de l'e-commerce et de la
vente à distance les ventes en ligne ont
augmenté de 20 % au 2e trimestre par
rapport à 2012 Arnaud Montebourg a
dévoilé lundi le nom des chefs des
groupes qui dirigeront les 34 plans
industriels Bernard Charles PDG de dasso
système en fait partie le dasso système
donc pour rappel à son siège social à
véisie au 3è trimestre l'achat de
logements ancien par des particuliers
qui veulent les louer a reculé de 5, 8 %
selon une étude réalisée par le réseau
d'agence Century 21 les chiffres
grimpent encore en Île-de-France dans
les Yvelines l'investissement locatif a
plongé de 14,5 %. les propriétaires en
fin de bail préféreraient revendre leurs
biens plutôt que de chercher un nouveau
locataire le réseau met en cause la
complexité de la nouvelle loi sur la
fixation des loyers le concours Créarif
quartier 2013 est lancé il s'adresse aux
personnes ayant une idée ou un projet de
création d'activité et habitant en
Île-de-France sur un des territoires de
la politique de la ville les zones
urbaines sensibles par exemple les
lauréats seront accompagnés dans leur
projet cette année la chambre de métier
et de l'artisanat est partenaire de
cette F vêtement pour la première fois
on écoute Noël Colin il y aura 20
lauréat et parmi ces 20 lauréat il y
aura une personne un futur artisan qui
aura la chance de participer à une
formation que on appelle cap jeun
dirigeant qui est plutôt post création
et qui
qui permet de participer à une vingtaine
une dizaine d'ateliers sur le suivi post
création d'entreprise et vous avez
jusqu'au 31 octobre pour vous inscrire
via le site internet qui s'affiche et on
finit avec la fête du jour on en parlait
dans le JT de mardi aujourd'hui on
célèbre la fête de voisins au travail
une première en France mais cet
événement compterait déjà pardon 20
millions de participants dans 36 pays on
passe maintenant à
l'entretien
l'association voiture enco a inauguré
une nouvelle plateforme de mobilité
bouger vers l'emploi ce lundi à trappe
il s'agit de la première du département
son but aider les personnes en recherche
d'emploi à retrouver un poste en
dépassant leur frein à la mobilité nous
avons en ligne max Descormier le
directeur de cette plateforme qui va
pouvoir nous en dire plus bonsoir
Monsieur décormers bonsoir madame alors
pour aider ces personnes comment vous y
prenez-vous alors comment ça se passe
ben écoutez déjà c'est clair la
plateforme bouger verspiture enco
fonctionne de telle manière à travailler
en relation avec les partenaires de
l'emploi donc l'idée c'est plutôt de
d'être en prescription donc à
savoir un conseiller mission locale ou
un conseiller pour l'emploi repère à une
personne dont il a le suivi et qui a une
difficulté de mobilité et donc nous
adresse pas sous forme de fiche de
liaison c'est en général l'outil un peu
classique effectivement dans le dans
auprès des acteurs de l'emploi une
demande donc cette demande arrive chez
nous elle est traitée par une
conseillère mobilité qui prend
directement contact avec cette personne
et puis par la suite ce qu'on appelle un
binant de compétence mobilité qui est
fait pendant 1 heure 1hure et demi donc
là l'idée c'est vraiment de balayer
l'ensemble des compétences ou des des
des capacités de la personne à se
déplacer soit en transport en commun ou
soit avec un véhicule qui a déjà un
permis voilà qui a besoin de se déplacer
pour d'ordre social ouou d'emploi voilà
on essaie de vraiment de ber les
capacités et et du coup vous proposez
alors soit une formation par la suite
c'est ça soit une flotte de véhicules
alors les formations ça peut être quoi
par exemple lire une carte se repérer
dans le métro oui voilà alors déjà dans
un premier temps ça peut aussi être tout
simplement une information de base parce
que et on s rend compte assez souvent
par toute simple méconnaissance un petit
peu de ce qui existe l'offre de
transport en commun bien les gens ont du
mal à se déplasser donc une simple
information bien ciblée sur des horares
de train une ligne qui résiste la
capacité à à prendre les correspondances
et cetera donc on arrive déjà à à régler
une forme d'autonomie de mobilité de de
ce type si c'est pas le cas mais
effectivement on met en place ce qu'on
appelle la formation mobilité sous forme
de module alors ça peut être une
première un premier module effectivement
d'apprendre à se déplacer à savoir lire
un plan une carte euh voilà mémoriser
effectivement un itinéraire euh ensuite
ça peut être tout simplement bah de de
la capacité à prendre les transports en
commun donc ça si on détecte que la
personne avec la simple formation qu'on
lui donne est en capacité de prendre les
transport en commun mais effectivement
là on rend notre
service on voit d'ailleurs à l'image les
les les images de l'inauguration de de
ce lundi
avec voilà il y avait deux personnes qui
étaient venu pour témoigner donc une qui
expliquait effectivement que vous
l'aviez aidé à se repéré dans dans le
métro elle est originaire de Mayotte
pardon et puis il y avit une autre
personne Malica qui elle son son souci
c'est que que les transports en commun
en fait commencit trop tard par rapport
à son travail dans ce cas-là la solution
pour elle c'est le prêt la location d'un
véhicule voilà location d'un véhicule
Renault puisquon a un partenariat avec
Renault bien évidemment sur le
territoire donc là c cette personne
était en emploi donc là on a on a
vraiment plutôt rendu le le service de
de de de permettre le maintien d'une
personne en emploi parce qu'on a aussi
des cette particularité c'est que
souvent les gens peuvent décrocher leur
emploi parce qu'il y a une problématique
de mobidité donc là c'est un cas figure
de quelqu'un qui avait déjà un emploi
qui avait sa propre voiture bon qui qui
avait une voiture en mauvais état donc
voà qui du coup s'en est séparé et et
vernau on a aussi V la la difficulté
qu'elle pouvait avoir donc tout de suite
on a mis en uvre une une comment un
contrat de location et puis là donc en
fait très très clairement pendant 3 mois
à 6 mois elle va pouvoir bénéficier de
ce service elle fera régulièrement des
des points écoutes avec Valérie petit
qui est la conseillère mobilité la
plateforme de traape qui la su
et qui qui va du coup par la suite
pouvoirah l'aider finalement à acquérir
d'elle-même un véhicule tout à fait on
va monter un dossier avec elle
effectivement de voir comment on peut
l'aider dans le cadre d'un microcrédit
social pour lui permettre effectivement
d'accéder à un véhicule d'occasion soit
par le le le réseau de Renault ou soit
par un autre un autre dispositif qui
s'appelle les autos du cœur qui qui
fonctionne aussi pour aider les gensilà
accéder au véhicule bien max Descormier
merci on est un peu pris par le temps je
vous remercie en tout cas de DEES
écoutez merci à vous je suis désolé de
pas pouvoir avoir été présent sur le
plateau parce que voilà l'actualité
était effectivement suite à
l'inauguration voilà mais on a pu au
moins vous avoir en ligne et c'est déjà
ça merci beaucoup en tout cas c'est
l'heure maintenant du dossier de la
semaine pour le dossier de la semaine
nous nous sommes intéressés à l'emplo
des jeunes dans les quartiers populaires
une des priorités affichées du
gouvernement le point dans les ivelines
un reportage réalisé avec Jonathan
villman et elodim moine en France les
jeunes sont une des populations les plus
touchées par le chômage 24,6 % et quand
ces jeunes viennent des quartiers
populair trappes Mandel jolie ou Les
Mureaux les données explosent le taux de
chômage des jeunes dans les zones
urbaines sensibles grimpe à 40,4 % pour
les pouvoirs publics c'est devenu une
priorité en avril le président François
Hollande se rendait au EUR il annoncé
plus de conseillers PUL emploi dans les
banlieux et des exonérations fiscales
pour les entreprises qui favorisent une
politique d'insertion régulièrement des
ministres viennent sur le territoire
pour signer des emplois d'avenir le mois
dernier c'était au tour de François lami
ministre délégué à la ville d'afficher à
trappe les mesures prises pour les
jeunes on va développer un nouveau
dispositif qui est celui des des emplois
francs qui va un dispositif qui qui
donne une chance supplémentaire un jeune
tout particulièrement diplômé qui est
souvent stigmatisé à cause de son
adresse voilà et puis il y a la la
convention qu'on vient de signer avec
bonoamont qui va bien entendu
s'appliquer à traap mais partout
ailleurs sur le territoire sur le
développement d'entrepreneuriat social
entre autres et puis sur ce qu'on
appelle les clauses d'insertion
c'est-à-dire ces heures de travail qui
seront réservés sur les marchés entre
autres de rénovation urbaine mais pas
que euh à des jeunes issus jeunes ou
moins jeunes d'ailleurs issus de de ces
quartier sur le terrain comment cela se
passe-t-il premier point sur la
situation à la Mission Locale fr c
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le directeur
de la Mission Locale de cqutin en
Yveline et de ses environs alors en
France dans les quartiers populaires le
taux de chômage des jeunes est deux fois
etis plus élevé que la moyenne nationale
est-ce que la situation est similaire
dans les ivelines oui bah c'est un
phénomène qu'on rencontre aussi dans les
ivelines enfin qu'on rencontre sur tout
le territoire donc aussi dans les
ivelines et sur 51 ivelines il est clair
que sur les dans les communes et dans
les quartiers qui font l'objet de la
politique de la ville le taux de chômage
des jeunes est plus élevé et ce taux de
chômage il est plus élevé à
qualification égale donc ce qui pose
vraiment problème ce n'est pas
uniquement au départ un problème de
déficit de qualification alors
apparemment les écarts augmentent pour
pour les quartiers populaires par
rapport à la au reste de la France
depuis 2008 comment ça s'explique en
effet on avait observé en 2008 une forte
augmentation du nombre de jeunes se
présentant pour la première fois à la
Mission Locale c'était des jeunes
souvent assez âgés qui avaient travaillé
et qui ont été les premières victimes du
retournement de la conjoncture c'était
des jeunes qui étaient en intéring qui
était en CDD voire en CDI qui n'avait
pas eu besoin jusque- là de la Mission
locale et puis qui là bah se retrouvant
confronté aux difficultés donc la crisee
plus finalement les quartiers populaires
alors votre rôle est d'accompagner et
d'aider ces jeunes à s'insérrer
professionnellement concrètement vous
vous y prenez comment alors pour les
jeunes du territoire de Saint-Quentin on
accueille environ 3500 jeunes chaque
année nous avons trois antennes une à
aencour une à trappe et une à guuill
encour pour leur offrir un service de
proximité euh ces jeunes ils
seront accueillis la première fois et
puis accompagnés dans leur parcours
toujours par le même conseiller pour
éviter qu'ils aient à raconter leur
histoire à 36 personnes donc ce
conseiller il est généraliste il va
traiter toutes les problématiques du
jeûne par contre en ce qui concerne
l'emploi et la recherche d'emploi
concrète ça ça va être assuré par des
conseillers qui sont dédiés et il y a
des conseillers sur chacune des antennes
donc qui vont animer les ateliers de
recherche d'emploi qui vont travailler
avec les jeunes les techniques de
recherche d'emploi et puis qui vont une
bonne partie de leur travail aussi c'est
de faire le rapprochement entre les
offres d'emploi collecté par la Mission
locale et les jeunes envoyer leur
candidature mesure phare du gouvernement
les emplois d'avenir fin 2012
l'association envie attrape en recruté
deux ouvert aux jeunes de moins de 26
ans peu diplômé il donne la priorité aux
habitants des zones urbaines sensibles
les entreprises du secteur non marchand
reçoivent une aide de l'État à hauteur
de 75 % du SMIC 130 ont été signés via
la Mission Locale Isou et sooso sont
toujours en poste chez Envie leur
directeur ne regretteent rien il y a
aussi le financement qui était aussi
intéressant parce que en tant
qu'association on est obligé de faire
attention au à nos charges en trésorerie
plus effectivement des gens qui avaient
déjà un niveau correct et qui étaient
sur truc qui était motivé voilà
l'association récupère répare et revend
du matériel électroménager elle compte
20 contrats d'insertion dont Maxime
trapiste de 26 ans il a arrêté l'école
il y a 10 ans et enchaîné jusqu'à
aujourd'hui des petits boulots en
intérim parce que j'avais besoin
d'argent et parce que à l'école c'était
pas ça quoi je m'ennuyais j'aimais pas
trop rester derrière un bureau donc
voilà fallait de l'action et du coup je
suis parti travailler son contrat
d'insertion dure 4 mois renouvelable
jusqu'à 2 ans l'objectif pour envie lui
permet de trouver au plus vite un emploi
stable l'idée c'est de résoudre déjà
s'ils ont des problématiques sociales
qui renc compte par exemple d'accès à
des logement des démarches
administratives c'est les aider à ce
niveaau-là pour après les idées au
niveau professionnel également c'est
résoudre un petit peu bah les freins à
l'emploi et pouvoir garantir leur future
employabilité depuis septembre un
nouveau contrat est également disponible
les contrats francs pour les entreprises
une prime de 5000 € s'il recrutent un
jeune de moins de 30 ans résidant dans
les quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville aujourd'hui on a
signé des emplois d'avenir avec environ
70 employeurs dont un certain nombre
d'employeurs qui n'avaient jamais
recruté des jeunes ayant ce profil là et
on peut espérer que ça soit un peu la
même chose sur pour les emplois
Fran junior fait partie de ces jeunes
qui ont été épaulés par la Mission
locale avec ses parents et ses cinq
frères et sœurs il grandit dans le
quartier du valfouré à mont-elajolie il
a été confronté au préjugés sur les
quartiers populaires mon professeur
d'art plastique que j'avais au collège
donc à à Montel
jolie nous orienter vers vers les BP
mais ça sert à rien n'allez pas en
seconde générale vous perdez votre temps
mais de toute manière vous finirez vos
rien et cetera je vous assure c'est
véridique en 2003 il déménage à trappe
et il passe le bac un dug
d'administration économique et sociale
en poche il commence à travailler mais
ce qu'il souhaite c'est être son propre
patron avec l'aide d'un parrain de la
Mission locale il lance son entreprise
de vente de produits de cosmétique et de
coiffure en tant qu'auto-entrepreneur
pas suffisant pour en vivre mais
l'expérience paye malgré des études
courtes il trouve un poste de commercial
et 2 ans plus tard un ancien fournisseur
lui propose de meilleures perspectives à
Paris cette fois ouais je vais faire une
super promo comme ça sera contente voilà
bon ben c'est super merci Flavie bah de
rien ça se passe très très bien donc il
y a un suivi de
clientèle on présente les différents
produits les nouveautés on fait aussi un
petit peu de service aprèsvente gestion
des conflits ronté d'information selon
lui trappe est une ville qui bouge et
agit pour ses jeunes on lui a donné sa
chance pour la suite tout est questions
de motivation à partir du moment où vous
mettez dans la tête que vous que vous
venez de trap euh que vous êtes
originaire d'un pays
quelconque et que vous entre guillemet
vous vous
formatez donc avec ces idées il y a un
blocage qui se fait voilà il faut
vraiment donc tout
écarté se dire bah qu'on est monsieur et
madame tout le monde après c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir éventuellement
certaines inégalités mais c'est pas
partout et il faut vraiment se donner la
chance de réussir des chances de
réussite c'est aussi ce que souhaite
offrir l'association m Saou bonjour vous
êtes le directeur général de
mosaïqueche pour débuter vous pouvez
nous expliquer un petit peu le concept
c'est une boîte de recrutement mais un
peu particulière alors effectivement en
fait c'est une agence de recrutement
c'est un cabinet de recrutement à
lucratif c'est sa particularité qui a eu
dans une première un premier niveau de
vie de vouloir promouvoir les candidats
diplômés qui résident dans les quartiers
populairesou cré association il y a 5
ans originaire de scè Saint-Denis il
souhaitait faire changer le regard sur
les jeunes des quartiers populaires moi
j'avais eu envie de montrer en fait
qu'en banlieu il y avait aussi plein de
jeunes qui réussissaient plein de jeunes
qui arrivaient à à développer leurs
compétences à à décrocher des diplômes
de l'enseignement supérieur montrer
également qu'il y avait plein de jeunes
qui avaient envie de se lever le matin
qui avaiit envie d'aller bosser et que
malheureusement il y a des mécaniques il
y a des mécanismes de discrimination qui
existent qui sont soit direct ou
indirect qui fait qu'à un moment donné
même lorsqu'on est volontaire même
lorsqu'on est qualifié et bien il y a
une hérésie économique qui fait qu'à un
moment donné le recruteur qui recrute ne
rencontre pas le candidat du territoire
et euh malheureusement ça génère en fait
un taux de chômage explosif parfois dans
les quartiers en 5 ans mosaïque RH a
réussi à placer 1700 jeunes
d'île-de-fance leur démarche se veut
complémentaire avec les institutions
publiques pour Saï amouche il faut
coller aux besoins des entreprises des
partenariats sont ainsi créés avec les
sociétés locales comme cassidian à et
encour pour atteindre l'égalité des
chances en terme d'emploi mosaïque erage
tente également de trouver des candidats
ciblés pour des stages un accord a été
mis en place avec l'Université de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline n trouve hyper
important d'aider les jeunes qui ont des
niveaux Bac + 3 bac + 4 bac + 5 de faire
des stages dans des entreprises
prestigieuses des stages de qualité pour
leur donner déjà dès le démarrage en
fait la possibilité d'avoir un CV un peu
muscler avoir un niveau de de connexion
avec des entreprises à forte notoriété
suffisant à partir du moment où on a ces
ces ces ces missions qui nous sont
proposées et bien il s'agit de trouver
le plus rapidement possible les
candidats qui vont bien et le la
deuxième étape de notre processus de de
fonctionnement c'est de rentrer en
contact avec ce qu'on appelle des
prescripteurs donc ce sont soit en fait
les universités qui sont sur des
territoires soit des acteurs locaux et
ça peut être les missions locales les
associations de quartiers parfois le Pô
emploi qui vont nous pousser des CV de
qualité et nous on va ensuite les
évaluer mesurer l'écart entre les
critères objectifs de l'entreprise et et
pas subjectif donc évidemment c'est
aussi à nous d'intervenir si on nous
demande systématiquement des hommes et
qu'on refuse des femmes si on nous
demande systématiquement en fait des des
des profils bac+ 5 type école de
commerce on leur explique qu'il y a
aussi de très bonnes candidatures à
l'université voyez c'est ça le le
travail de médiation qu'on doit faire
alors du coup dans les evelines euh les
résultats quels sont-il ils sont assez
positifs je pense alors sans être
présent physiquement on a eu la
possibilité de répondre en fait à des
demandes spontanées d'entreprises
locales et il faut savoir que nous avons
réussi à peu près 74 placements en
l'espace de 5 ans donc c'est prometteur
et on se dit si on était présent
physiquement si on avait la possibilité
d'augmenter notre niveau de prospection
sur le bassin d'emplois de de G en cours
en cours et bien on pourrait imaginer en
fait gagner d'autres entreprises
d'autres missions et pouvoir ensuite
diffuser ses opportunités sur les
acteurs du du territoire mosaïque à rage
devrait donc s'implanter très
prochainement dans le département au
niveau de son fonctionnement financier
l'association compte principalement sur
la participation de ses entreprises
partenaires seul 8 % du budget provient
de
subvention merci d' d'avoir été avec
nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine